hi everyone thank you so much for
joining me today
my name is dani and i'm an architect
based in vancouver bc
have you ever felt stuck in your career
and
imagined yourself transitioning into a
completely
new path well my guest today
has done that several times
evelyn started her career in
architecture and
after becoming a licensed architect
transitioned
to working for an organization that
connects architects with non-profits
then she decided to go and get her mba
and her mpa
she worked as a strategic lead she
worked as a managing director for a
commercial real estate firm
and she now works as a senior experience
designer at slack
she is also the founder of practice of
architecture
and now their new podcast practice
disrupted
where they help people and practices
find new ideas for growth
in a world that is constantly changing
she's also the first female treasurer of
the aia nationals board
we are living in incredibly uncertain
times
but also very exciting times entire
industries are changing
traditional roles are being challenged
and job security is definitely
not guaranteed and job satisfaction is
more
nebulous than ever so in this interview
evelyn and i talk about her various
career transitions
some practical tips for young architects
and we also talk about the industry
and the need for architecture firms to
break out of the traditional method of
practice so that they can be
more relevant more involved and
more profitable it was very interesting
for me to hear her point of view
especially because i have been
questioning the direction of the
industry myself
as well as my own career path so
i hope you find it interesting so here
it is
could you just talk about your
career like all your career pivots
a little bit and
[Laughter]
and how long do you how long do you have
um well i i don't know i mean i think if
if anything i would hope that people
know that
a career is really a journey i was
always one of those individuals that
wanted to
be an architect i don't know ever since
i was in the fourth grade i was one of
those silly architects that knew like at
a super young age like
i want to be an architect without
knowing what an architect actually did
until i became an architect and i
realized
i was so disconnected from the end users
of our buildings
even though i was designing schools and
community centers
my time was spent more with this the
city
um and county staff we were working with
or
the school board than you know the
actual students
and the actual teachers and the people
in the community and
and that's where i wanted to spend my
time hearing those voices
because i felt that that was where i
could make the biggest impact so i
ultimately left architecture to go work
for a non-profit organization up here in
the bay area
called public architecture and manage a
program
which has it's now called the oneplus
program
but essentially was established pre-the
great recession
when architects were at our you know we
were doing really
well the economy is in a highest wing
and we're asking architects to give
one percent of their billable hours
towards the public good pro bono
which if you think about it collectively
would mean that it would be the biggest
pro bono design firm globally
uh so so the promise was super
interesting
but a lot of the architects were having
problems finding nonprofit organizations
to actually
serve and create projects with so
i was the first person to come on and
look at how do we create those
partnerships with nonprofit
organizations
and then i realized even myself as an
architect
um all other than unlicensed working
towards licensure
i was really ill-equipped
uh to talk about the value proposition
and i think
architects always talk about we need to
be much
better about how we talk about our value
and deliver because we're always
under pricing our services and people
don't understand our value
well i i felt that i wasn't
fully able to articulate that to the
nonprofit organizations
and it was clear that the nonprofit
organizations and the majority of the
public only felt
that you know architects are only needed
if you
have a new ground up building right not
necessarily
like architects can even rearrange your
space
to help get better operations and
processes
going or that by doing certain things to
your existing space
you actually could raise the potential
um
of donors and the amount that donors are
willing to give
just purely because you come off as more
professional and organized
in the way you present yourself so
i took that um notion and i went back to
school to get my mba
i ended up tagging on an mpa which is
public administration
because ultimately um the mba is much
more qualitative and i felt more
quantitative
and i felt that mpa is much more
qualitative and it was about
research methodology methodologies
used at the community level to gather
information and then use that data
to make decisions um at the civic level
and i figured that i could use that
to play out at a lot of different
various consulting posts
i landed at a consulting group called mk
think actually it's an architecture and
design group called mk think that had
a strategic studio as one of its core
competencies
and i led that for multiple years i
went to work with a firm a friend
actually
on the consultant side of workplace
experience consulting at several
different brokerages
with the same team our team moved
between brokerages
and then i ended up taking that
workplace experience and transitioning
it to slack
internally on the client side so that's
where i am now
right so a lot of pivots so
just to backtrack a little bit
when you went to do your mba because i
think there are quite a few
architects who want to pivot their
careers they go in and do their mba
did you have a clear idea of what you
what kind of job you wanted to do after
getting the mba
no i i mean that was that was an unusual
journey for me
too it sounds like i had an idea i
really didn't
i was but i was in a point in my life
where i didn't know what the what
the next step was i was really
struggling honestly internally
because i had wanted to be an architect
for so long and then
i felt personally i kind of felt a loss
of identity because i was like well if i
don't want to be an architect then what
do i want to be
um i was i was younger i didn't have a
family
i didn't have a boyfriend i had no
connections um
and i just kind of took the risk and
uh what i felt wasn't actually a much
needed break
um so i actually you know there's all of
these
there's even within the mba program
there's these groups
like the green building club or the real
estate development club or the building
tech club
and i i actually specifically just
it's like what if i just take a break
from architecture all together
and explore if anything
speaks to me um and it was actually
through that break that i realized i
needed to do something that aligned a
little bit more closely with
with architecture because i actually
missed it um
but but yeah i it's like if i were to
go do that now i think you know as a
mother
you know now married it's much harder
it would it would be much harder
honestly for me to make that decision to
do that
now um so it was kind of like a right
time right place
and i just took the risk and took on the
debt and
kind of just dove head in right where
you let serendipity guide you
i i did but i knew you know
and maybe maybe i was a bit naive but i
felt like
well at least the very least i come out
of this with an
mba um so i've got to be able to
use to leverage that into another role
somehow
um so i i felt like
you know i i wasn't just sitting around
doing nothing trying to figure out
what's next i felt like i was like
actively pursuing what's next
right so if you could have gone back
before you did your mark would you have
just done the mba um no so
so the and i think and maybe things are
all serendipity i do
think like i i think
luck there is a there is an amount of
luck and in life
um but as my husband has said multiple
times to me i think
i think like some of the things that we
find comes out of luck
it also happens out of good intention
and
planning ultimately um
so the reason why i went and got my mark
after i finished my brx it was a
post-professional
type of three-month
degree was because my beard was so
technical and i really wanted to
explore the theoretical side of
architecture i felt like there was
a lot of things going on in computer
graphics um or just computer modeling
that we weren't touching
when i in my undergrad and i didn't know
enough i mean how
how many people know in high school that
architecture programs are so different
um
i mean i i thought i knew a lot of this
a senior but i
like i knew enough to go and look for an
accredited program but i didn't realize
like
the huge swings in the differences in
curriculum that those accredited
programs could really provide you
um so i i did it because i wanted a
theater
like i just i felt like i was missing an
important part
of my education um and i wouldn't take
that back
because i actually did this incredible
um
scenario planning studio with natalia
devries
from mbr um nbr plus tv here tv
or nvrdb yes sorry within the mr
plus d program but natalie of nbr vd
um she she and michael speaks led this
scenario planning
studio which at a core was a lot of
how do you gather data to make decisions
on
a broader scale you know what type of
community
engagement do you need and it was
strategic planning so ultimately
if i like look at the arc of everything
i've done um like that was my favorite
studio throughout all
of my education um if i had realized
that sooner
i think i may have been able to actually
get to my career path
sooner um but it took me a while for me
to realize like that's the type of thing
that i actually want to be doing
so i mean hindsight no
i would have like if i had gone and done
my mba i would have missed out on that
very right it your path is kind of
interesting because i think a lot of
people find that
their br gets a little bit too
theoretical and it's not
technical enough so
yeah it's interesting that you went to
you went back to your mr
to get more of that theoretical
experience yeah
i also had this romantic notion of
wanting to be a teacher
that has never come to fruition so well
you're kind of a teacher now
because you're i guess doing all these
interviews
yeah thank you for that
[Music]
um so okay yeah that's interesting
so you because i think the
notion is that the
academics have to be more grounded in
reality the
um like architectural schooling has to
be more grounded in reality
um and be more relevant and it's
the academics i have to catch up with
the industry not
the other way around but yes i think i
mean that's an ongoing argument
right between academics and
practitioners i think
i think i mean for me the theoretical
side is more important because that's
where you learn
approaches to problem solving and that's
an implementation and execution and
and that's a little bit different than
um
i i i don't know so i um maybe we'll get
around to this
but the way we approach traditional
practice um
is is kind of failing i think
our profession a little bit like it's um
the business model is failing so i would
hate to see education
focus on purely creating people that can
create construction documents when
that's kind of the lowest denominator of
our value that we provide as architects
like i would much rather see education
producing
um interesting and unique problem
solvers and systemic thinkers because i
think that's where our value really is
right right and that's the work that
you're doing with
practice of architecture yeah
a little bit about that yeah of course
uh
so i i mean i i've been very i've been
come very public um about the need for
what i see traditional practice to
evolve i actually really enjoyed my time
at mk think because it provided a
unique platform as a strategic
thinker and as a leader one of the
leaders of the strategy group
um at a what i would consider a small to
medium-sized firm so
a lot of people when they think about
strategy
right they think like oh it's the
gentlers and the hk's and the perkins
and wills who can only
afford kind of the overhead to pay for
strategists and researchers
mk-pink was this medium-sized firm that
really made strategy its core competency
um and the revenue it brought in was on
par
if not above i i feel what the
architects brought in
partly because we could even just charge
more from an hourly rate perspective
um so it's a good model of how we can
evolve traditional practice
even at a smaller scale and
and expand our services and raise our
value and have more touch points with
our clients
and i think it's a model that more
architecture firms need to
follow to remain relevant and to to be
i i hear a lot of architects talk about
how you know they want to be
you know the first person that a client
picks like picks up the phone with when
when they need to discuss something
about business or intricacies or
they want to be that go-to knowledge
asset uh
and we we swim in such a narrow lane
that it's hard for clients to fully
understand
um that we have other capabilities until
we start actively participating in other
areas
right trying to get the architect more
into the phase
zero right right so i guess a long story
short now i'll get off my soapbox
was that practice of architecture was
kind of founded to help
architects think more about the other
services that they can be providing
to really bring in examples from other
industries about how we can
even change our approaches to business
development
marketing what are some of the examples
um okay so and i don't know hopefully
this is not a replay
of of a previous um
of a previous comment i made in another
interview but
um a good example would be for instance
i've seen a lot more architects
advertising on instagram right now
and when you click through a lot of them
i actually reached out every time this
happened i reached out to them directly
when you they click through a lot of
them you just land on their website
um which is great i mean i guess you're
you're
engaging your your numbers on your
website
going up but you're not getting paid um
on the amount of clicks that you get on
your website
right so anytime that you do not put a
contact form
um in front of that click or or just
after that click
it's like an opportunity it's a it's a
lost lead right like that was a person
who
you got interested in but you didn't do
anything to capture
their information um so even simple
things like that where if you click on
every single arc like
other instagram ad i'm sure you get it
you know
here's five quick tips to download even
your
name and email address so it's i mean
even something as small as that is
something that i think we can learn from
right yeah i think the whole um
marketing through online is
fairly new to a lot of firms and they
still have this notion that
it's word of mouth or which is a really
big part of how you get clients but
word of mouth or reference and they
don't really take the time to
advertise or learn how to advertise in
these
different different media streams
yeah and then there's simple things that
um
so the architecture from that worked for
for a long time we were still doing time
cards in excel
like there's just simple things that you
can automate so it's just not as tedious
of a process
and then you can use that time um on
other things
uh to to build your business so
so those are those are like the more
simple things the more interest the
harder things
is just you know how do you look at your
addition like your current talent pool
and your current clients and identify
um potential services that you could be
selling
above and beyond what you're doing right
now
so one of the things that you were
selling at
mmk mtk i think
mk think was
strategizing on how you can use the
spaces rather than just doing the
construction
it was it was um and we did we did get
into operations and processes in some
instances but
um it was i would say with strategic
consulting and that sometimes you even
go
to the large consulting firms for um but
it's around the health environment
so like one project that i wasn't
directly
um directly put on but
it's one of the more interesting ones to
tell is
that we were working with the san
francisco unified school district
so a lot of students for instance rely
on
school for their their food
so they were looking at you know how
what
what is the cost on the district
versus the gain to the the children
um to to one provide an additional meal
so can they do breakfast and lunch
and then how do they
create what are the operational
processes based on
their current facilities to provide
like a good health healthy
alternative meals so we
so the group went in and they took
account of every single piece of kitchen
equipment
and every school that had a kitchen
and then they set up like how do you
where do we need to centralize the
kitchen for san francisco unified
district
and based on the equipment available at
the other kitchens how far do we need to
par-cook the food
before we deliver it on-site and how do
we optimize
kind of our delivery stream to save the
most money
as we can so we can serve the most
students so that
that was i mean it's space related but
it also has like a social justice
overlay to it and it was you know
serving the community so
so that was the type of strategic work
that um we were involved in
so was that completely separated from
the construction work or did that
eventually funnel in the or was that a
method of funneling in the
architectural work um so it
i would say so the strategic work we
consider we considered
strategy a strategic studio so sometimes
it led to construction work
sometimes it didn't but at any rate it
always
provided us to not provide us provided
us an opportunity to expand
the different clients that we were
working with um
we we didn't end up on the
implementation side of that one
there was um i'm i'm still working on
and off i have
a long-standing uh partnership with uc
hastings that i
established when i was at mk think and
i am still doing work for them this
you know with them to this day but
essentially we did
the long-range strategic plan for their
campus
and the cfo is keeping me on to make
sure that we implement
successfully against that long-range
strategic plan um
so i've been on the client side in that
case and i'm selecting the architects to
build
or are part of the architect selection
um and helping
the university do programming and
planning um
and now we're supporting them on wave
binding and signage
uh because they have a very they have a
distributed urban campus they have
it's an urban campus with multiple
different buildings um
so yeah we're finding lots of different
ways to support them strategically that
doesn't necessarily always end up with a
building
and there there will always be um the
architects that one
don't consider me an architect anymore
which
took me which is i feel hurtful but i'll
get over it
but but too um because i i
very much consider what i'm doing like
still architecturally related i
i draw from my architectural background
a lot but two i think
you know there will be those individuals
that like if i'm not building
doing a building i'm not an architect um
and to that i i just have to say
um you know again these opportunities
provide additional value to your clients
they will be calling you
when they don't need a building um which
means that they will absolutely be
calling you when they do need a building
but
if you know if we're such a relationship
based
um service provider then these
opportunities are really expanding those
relationships
yeah and i think even at a smaller scale
i was just speaking to
um an architect who oh that's the video
that i posted in the women in
architecture group it was the architect
who works with indigenous communities
and um he's a sole proprietor but even
he's very involved in like the initial
stages of the project where they're
trying to get funding
where they're trying to strategize on
how they can
build up their like employment
employment rates in the community and
doesn't necessarily translate into an
architectural project but
like it's a part of his services he
doesn't really market it that way but
you know it is and um it sometimes leads
to architectural work sometimes
it doesn't but yeah it seems like um
being able to be a part of that
decision making process right in the
beginning
is where architects should all
want to go right i mean if you're in
that position then you're usually
actually the one setting the like
helping set the budget
you know for a capital campaign um
and and quite frankly i actually like
being on
on the client side and being the one
who's hiring the architects
because then i can i can take that and i
can say like okay um
i i end up reaching out to a lot of
architects who actually don't
make it who aren't selected to build our
products and slack and just say
um you know the next interview you go in
to here's kind of five to seven tips
that you might want to consider
and that's that's different to your
approach to really make you stand out
um can you can you talk about those tips
um okay well get super high level i i
mean i think this is the most obvious
one
because i've been i've been the
diversity hire that people drag along
to interview right but if you are going
to so blatantly do that make sure that
those individuals actually have a voice
in the presentation
and they're not just like a pretty face
that's sitting and smiling
throughout the presentation so that
would be like a really
really easy one but sometimes like a
principle is not going to change
that internally like i feel like
um the individual got that got dragged
along
could probably not say that to the
principal of the firm
which is with as much impact as i could
as a potential client
saying you you didn't show
us the value of your team because you
didn't let your entire team speak
um so i feel like as
as a as somebody who's hiring the
architects i almost um
i'm giving the principal the business
case right for
changing what they're doing versus the
internal person struggling saying i
really wish i could have a voice
you know during these interviews
right um do you have any
tips for architecture students who are
in school right now because i feel like
the industry is
changing so much especially with kovid
that
i think a lot of people are going to
have to be equipped with skills
outside of architecture but they're
skills that are not really
defined so yeah
how would you um yeah i mean i
it's it's so tears
um i would
i would um as a student i think
um people always want to talk to
students
and help guide careers right or
help students figure out the next path
this was even true
in my late 20s when i went back to
school and i would just say like hi and
you know i'd reach out to people and say
hi i'm an mba student i would really
like to learn more about your path
like would you like do you mind
connecting
like i would say a little bit more what
i'm
more specifically interested in learning
about somebody's path and then
ask for like a 10 to 15 minute phone
call which usually
in the best case scenario always turned
into a half hour or hour long phone call
um but i think if you're if you're kind
of struggling with how do i
use these skills i'm getting in
architecture school and where do i want
to end up
and if it's not necessarily in
traditional practice like now is your
opportunity
to kind of create an identity on a
network like linkedin and kind of just
cold email people that you are
interested
in learning a bit more about how they
got there
there's so many new jobs and fields that
come
that have opened up i think in the like
in the
you know in the last 10 years that
you will find that a lot of people that
are in these positions i'm like one
might be
um like data data visualization like
even if you think about
if you think about um kind of how
like even the elections right um
how much more data you see on television
screens right now about like where
elections are headed how the vote's
going
um versus how people just usually talked
to that data before so there's
there's been this whole new data vis
career that's taken off um
and and that's happened i think you know
with
like that's really accelerated within
the last five years so people
that are in that field right now are
relatively new to the field themselves
so like here's a great opportunity to
see like how did you identify that
career path
you know what actually led you there
what steps did you need to take and just
just be be the inquisitive student that
you already are
and and ask those questions and i think
by asking a lot of questions
you'll get to answers about your own
career sooner
i think you also mentioned in the
other interview with joanne that it's
like if you are looking for a career
pivot it's really
hard to get a job just by like cold
resume
it's usually through networking
and yeah i mean i think it's always
especially within
the tech world i i mean i was extremely
lucky but i think it's
it's always easier to get a referral
with from from somebody within the
company than it is to do
like the cold email so um
so if you have these informational
interviews and then something comes up
like in their company and you haven't
even reached out to a person for like
six months
i think it's it's easy enough to say you
know i really enjoyed our conversation
it was aspirational i saw this interview
i saw this opening that i
saw pop up on your career site and i
just wanted to let you know that i was
as applying if you could put in a good
word for me that would be wonderful
and um i'd like to find out more
about it could you redirect me to the
hiring manager or
would you be willing to have a like have
a conversation
um it just and this is true of
architecture firms too
right um so even if you don't want to
leave traditional practice which
there are definitely people who want to
stay stay in it and
and are like i was never a good designer
there's definitely good designers who i
think
need to stay in architecture um
but um even then like you could do these
same informational interviews
with with architecture firms and you'll
actually find that principles are much
more accessible
again when you're coming from the point
of like i'm a student i've seen your
work on this i see
your talk your article can i get 10 to
15 minutes of your time
um so just think about like what an
impact that leaves then
when later you are going through the
recruiting team and you you can say hey
i talked to your principal
earlier about your firm and this is what
i'm really excited about
so yeah right
right and what about
um so i think a lot of people
you also talked about cleaning up your
google presence
making sure that everything that's on
there is what you want people to see
yeah i mean and it's i'm not saying that
you shouldn't have
a political voice even in this climate
but i just think
that you should be aware of everybody
reading that and that
um uh i mean even the things that we're
doing at the aia
and even our statement are our stronger
statement that came out regarding black
lives matter
and um it
it's device or you know it's it's
dividing
right we we did not bring the entire
membership along with that statement so
so just know that um
just be aware that what you say may turn
some people off um and if you're okay
with that then
by all means like use your voice
um but but if you're if you're not okay
with
with being judged on what you're saying
out in public then just don't say it out
in public
right right what about if you have a
um i think a lot of people have like a
side
side income side hustle and
let's say their web page leads straight
to that
which might not correlate
exactly with like where they want to go
with their careers
right um how
what do you think about that interesting
one i mean i've
i've always been very public about my
side hustles
um i've i've been i wrote i started
writing back in
oh i don't know 2004 before writing for
a blog was actually a thing
um
and i but i've always i don't know i've
always been very clear but i've also
been very clear because i
want whomever i work with to
to appreciate the fact that i'm engaged
there
um but again like i i
i think i think you just have to realize
the people you are attracting and the
people
you might be um discouraging with
whatever you put out there
um and know that you know and
there's definitely firms that are going
to be like you can't have a side hustle
so the truth of it is one i would not
want to work for those
firms but like two like they would very
quickly find out
um and they would probably just not
pursue me either so i
i i mean i guess i would just say like
be honest and true to who you are and
realize what you're putting out there
and
and who that attracts and who that
scares away so
and eventually you'll find the right
match that appreciates
you for who you are yeah hopefully i
mean i think i think there is the
ability for all of us to craft
to craft that i also think like um
i definitely had those jobs where it was
just just a job and i needed an income
um and that's okay like i learned from
those two so
um you know sometimes you end up there
but it's any any job you're in is
is only temporary until you're ready
until you find the next thing
so manage your expectations around that
as well
well can you talk about that a little
bit like your transition phase
i think you wrote up um an article
um pretty recently about um william
bridges this book
dropship oh yeah that was that was one
of our so that was one of our
collaborators on um practice of
architecture so i didn't write that
laura weiss actually wrote that
right okay um well did you did you read
it
did you read it oh i read the article i
haven't actually haven't read
the book i mean the interesting thing
about laura though is
um she she is a generation so i'm
generation x i would say she's a
generation older
than me and she made her last career
pivot
just within the last year so if
i guess the biggest lesson there is that
like it's you're never
it's never too late in your right right
even if you have given all of this time
to you know a profession we've i've been
talking to a lot of people about
one thing that architects and
particularly they struggle with is like
they're
we we see our career especially if you
go into traditional practice it's this
very linear path right
like everyone's focused on you should
get your license then once you get your
license you must be on this some
somewhere on the partner principal
partner check
um i think that's kind of detrimental
to to career building over the long term
because because then we forget like
there's other opportunities and then we
we we get in our own way because we're
like we've committed
so much time to this path like like how
could i ever step off of it
yeah you have to design your careers
as much as you you know design the
project absolutely
um sorry um so
just to go back to that transition face
a little bit so
in that article she um
they're talking about the
the crosswalk right and
as soon as you leave the sidewalk people
just want to get to the other side
but i think what uh bridges was saying
is that like you
want to try to stay and that yeah that
was a great metaphor
so can you talk a little bit about like
what that
phase of your life was like that
experience yeah i mean
so this happened recently actually i um
and i've been half public about it um
and and you know what my people at
slacknow so i recently joined a coaching
program
it is a five-figure
investment on my part to grow
the practice of architecture so for me
i had to sit with this decision for two
to three weeks um to really kind of
decide like is that something i
i want to take um you know and
and i was like i was questioning my own
ability to ever make that
like make back that money that i'm now
asking my family
to give up um so
so so yeah like that was like the
stepping off point right
but i decided to go for it and i'm all
in it
and i um we have a forthcoming
partnership announcement that we're
announcing later today
that like like like that so the class
the business coaching class already put
me in this new mindset
um that's going to accelerate my ability
to make
meaningful impact in the practice of
architecture um if i had just like tried
to do it on my own
um but but yeah it was a it was a
it was not a decision that i took
lightly and it was one that involved
my husband and our finances and where we
were and what we would have to
move around or postpone because of this
decision
so yeah i imagine decisions like that
get harder and harder
as you get
older in your life yeah make all the
tough decisions now when you're younger
i'm just kidding no i mean i am grateful
for having such a supportive
husband um but but yeah like that
like the stepping off part is always the
hardest i think
um yeah but also like after i got over
the hump and we committed i'm
i'm fully committed to making that money
back for my family
that's definitely a motivator
your husband's just like watching over
you and you do the work
i know before he was like why are you
staying up till 2 a.m like doing this
practice of architecture that isn't
making
up like really any money and now he's
like you better stay up until 2am
no just he's not like that but it
definitely was an internal mindset
like shift like um yeah right right well
i think
like you've already found a successful
career path in tech
and but you're coming back to
architecture and
and trying to help architects find um
their path and helping them expand their
vision of what they could do so i like i
love that
and i i really appreciate that well i do
love architects so that's
that's never been an issue with me it's
just how we
how we do business i want more
architects to be successful
and you're on the um board at the aia
as well right i am um i joke that i'm
often the fly on the wall
like the the one non non-traditional
architects
on on the very small national board um
i'm actually
the treasurer right now and um i'm
you know i'm in trying to refocus us in
terms of like
you know how how do we find you know
whether other partnerships that we can
create what are other
mechanisms that we can use to drive
revenue as a
as a membership organization that
doesn't so heavily rely
on our members paying to be a part of it
um
so and especially at times like this
so so that's i mean that's kind of
where my my focus is um
being there in addition to just being an
active participating member
so they are they on board with this new
approach to practice um like um
i mean no i like no but they don't they
don't have
to be right i i was i was voted on by my
peers
i also ran unopposed because no one i
mean honestly no one wants to be a
treasurer
um and this is not a fun year to be a
treasurer
nor is next year i actually think next
year is going to be much harder for us
so nor is next year going to be a fun
year to be a treasurer
but i see it as a strategic opportunity
there are definitely people that respect
my different point of view whether or
not they're willing to change their
practice
to to follow what i'm saying and to
is i'm equally respectful of
what what they need to do um and what
they think they need to do
to to continue um but
but should they ever want to change i
will be here to help and support them
why do you think that the role of the
architect is so
um entrenched in traditional practice
i oh there's so much um
yeah wow that's like a huge like
we could spend all like an entire
afternoon i think i'm packing that one
um i i think it's just
i mean a lot of it i think has to do
with this age-old apprenticeship
model of like how how we
go through leadership transition in our
firms or actually how we don't go
through leadership transition in
our firms um a lot of it is
a lot of it i think is just even um
the culture the studio culture that we
came out of
um so on on a podcast actually
coming up on practice disrupted in
in a few weeks we talked to two
past aias so american institute of
architecture student leaders
who actually co like codified
um like kind of a
uh they could they codified studio
culture
or like the rights of the student in
studio culture
into the nab the national architecture
now i'm getting like too deep in this
the national architecture accreditation
board um
like the the requirements to become an
accredited program
and it's been interesting it wasn't it's
an interesting it was an interesting
conversation to me because i
what i learned out of that is that my
experience in studio
has been very different than the
experience
of students coming out of studio today
like my studio was much and
and the whole thing that drove studio
culture was the fact that
you know a student's life was lost
staying up
48 hours you know getting in a car
accident
like preparing for finals not to say
that's not funny anymore but but i mean
not to say that that
i mean honestly not to say that that
isn't happening anymore but i do
feel be because because our because
architects
um architectural schools are still
referred to as lighthouses on campuses
but um but there is
like but the the student the i feel like
the studio culture that students are
graduating out of
right now are is much more collaborative
and less competitive
than the studio culture that i graduated
out of
and the studio culture that i graduated
with perpetuates
this firm culture of we can't share
anything with our peers
we can't share anything with even people
in our firm until they're quote unquote
ready
or they've like gone through this rite
of passage
um that's really kind of held us in this
traditional practice model
uh whereas like you know i see a lot of
i see a lot of collaboration and a
bigger entrepreneurial
spirit coming out of the next generation
um
but i also see them struggling because
they're going into
these firms with firm leaders that
graduated
in my studio culture so if we can get
through that dynamic
then hopefully we can come out on the
other side
but it's it's just like it's just like a
weird dynamic happening
right now that's um and there's just a
lot of older leadership still in firms
that's just
perpetuating um kind of
what they grew out of yeah that's
just one of like so many reasons why we
can't get out of traditional practice
but yeah and it's changing now too with
covet
um everything has moved online yeah
absolutely
yeah i don't know what's going to happen
to that collaborative studio culture
yeah it'll be interesting to see
although i do i just talked to a friend
who they're actually creating a virtual
space
um for for students
not a kid like it's not dissimilar from
second life for like
the academic perspective and like studio
so cool so i there's definitely
like people out there that are pushing
kind of
um even where we're headed from a
digital practice standpoint
right i don't know if you've heard of um
seth godin's
alt mba i have yeah
and so their model is like
everyone who's in the class is
participating like everyone has their
webcam turned on
so that it is really like being in a
classroom because
you know it doesn't work if you just
play a recording
or just do a one-way zoom call right
right absolutely um and
you even see this happening in firms
more right like we had video
conferencing
capabilities so long ago but even even
in go to meetings and zoom
like rarely would anybody actually turn
on their video cameras
so like you know so the pandemic has
kind of perpetuated at least
at least seeing everyone's face like on
the other end of a video conference
rather than
the agenda or just the presentation that
you're presenting
and the way that people are learning is
very different too
yeah absolutely i think it's going to
democratize architecture
hopefully yeah that would be a good
thing
yeah yeah and it kind of goes back to
you talking about your role as a teacher
right i mean i think like what you're
doing with the podcast and the videos i
think that's
probably like a more effective way of
teaching
younger people in some ways than like
the role of the studio instructor
that's i i mean i appreciate that view
so thank you um
yeah i i mean i've never really looked
at myself that way maybe
maybe i should but i i've definitely
especially now tried to make myself
available for people that have had
questions about career switching and
um and just my own path and and
and the next steps that they should take
sorry okay do you have any final tips
for
young architects um
no just just hang in there i get i don't
know hang in there
so one of the one of the things that i
really
um love about my current employer um
and by no me no means am i trying to
commercialize this
but um what so one of the things
that so slack orientation for one was
it's like a it's like a half week long
event
um we're also on boarding like 20 new
people a week
like like which coming from an
architectural world like i can't
imagine a firm on 20 people a week
um so we have a very intense orientation
program but one of the things that they
say
the first day that resonates that i wish
more architecture firms would say
um and if they aren't saying it to you
um
i hope it doesn't silence your voice at
all is that you
your life experiences makes you a
contributor from day one
so speak up um
have a voice have an opinion um if you
find yourself at a firm that doesn't
allow you to do that then maybe you
haven't landed at the right firm and you
should
take that into consideration um
but uh but there are definitely firms
out there
there that are that are willing to give
you a voice from day one and i think
that's important
i'm i learn a lot from
from the younger people that i talk to
it's sad to think that i'm on the older
end
of things these days but um yeah i i
learned it a lot and respect
respect that so i appreciate the
incoming generation and the voice that
they bring to the table
yeah and i think it's also the strength
of the firms from the older generation
to
um be more dynamic and change to
the way that younger people are doing
things so what did you think about the
interview
i would really love to hear your
thoughts in the comments
uh you can find resources and really
insightful articles
at www.practiceofarchitecture.com
and you can also listen to their podcast
practice disrupted
where they interview industry leaders
and
explore technology and cultural shifts
getting you to think about how you can
adjust your career
and your your practice to some of these
emerging trends practice of architecture
also just recently launched a
career assist program with an
organization called teal
where they help people wanting to
transition into
new career roles if you enjoy this video
please leave me a thumbs up and i would
really love to hear your thoughts
in the comments below so that's it for
today
and i'll see you in the next one